want to talk about Puerto Rico today I
was looking through Donald Trump's
Twitter account from the last couple of
days and I saw tweets about James Comey
I saw tweets about the corrupt failing
fake mainstream media tweets about
Roseanne Barr and wanting an apology
from ABC President Bob Iger but I didn't
see anything from Trump about this new
report which says that nearly 5,000
people died during an after Hurricane
maria in puerto rico and that number is
orders of magnitude higher than
previously reported and all along during
the recovery i was saying just based on
reports right i didn't make it up i was
saying that the number of dead is being
drastically under counted because
without electricity without
communication without water with road
closures how do we know how many people
are being found dead in remote small and
rural areas we didn't know and now we're
closer to knowing and the harvard study
i'm referencing was published earlier
this week in the new england journal of
medicine it reminded me that the
official estimate for a long time said
that 64 people died 64 when the real
number according to the Harvard study is
4645 why would the official number be 64
and why would it be kept that way as
long as possible well a couple different
things number one 64 is the number that
supposedly died from the hurricane
itself like as the hurricane was going
on but it doesn't include the number of
people that died as a result of problems
caused by the hurricane but the other
reason why the current administration
would have held the number of dead at 64
for as long as possible is because 4645
dead makes the federal government
response look really bad which it was it
was Anna morally bad response and
everything from the trauma caused by the
hurricane itself to the disruption of
health care services to loss of
utilities like electricity and water for
people that are chronically ill disease
that spreads when you have no power or
no water and stagnant water food supply
issues all of these things obviously led
to more than 64 deaths and to put the
number in context right 4,600
dead about 3,000 people died in 9/11
right 4,600 died in the puerto rican
hurricane and it's aftermath 2,400 died
in Pearl Harbor of course the population
of the US was far lower than so
proportionately we've got to account for
that but this is 4,600 people that died
it is the worst disaster in the United
States by death toll in the last hundred
years and yeah Puerto Rico is in the
United States at the time remember Pat
people were talking about you know
defenders of the administration we're
saying listen we don't have ultimate
responsibility for international
disasters Porto Ricans are American
Porto Rico is part of the United States
and the big difference is that when we
look at the number dead in Puerto Rico
versus some of the other disasters that
have been bad disasters over the last
hundred years most of the deaths in
Puerto Rico would have been preventable
given the right response and the right
resources I'm not saying all of them I'm
not saying it's a reasonable standard to
say that the government should have been
able to mobilize so quickly that not a
single person died beyond those original
suppose at 64 I'm not saying that but
what I am saying is that many of these
deaths would have been preventable had
the response been different yeah I mean
do you think that if the numbers were
more accurate during the hurricane and
in the weeks after it would have
encouraged more people to contribute to
the Red Cross that would have encouraged
FEMA to get there a lot quicker and do
more and I don't know you know Trump
seed even try to do something else or
would people still think that Puerto
Rico is just some foreign land that we
don't have to concern ourselves there
are people that would think that no
matter what I do think you're right that
the the lack of accurate reporting early
on made it seem as though the problem
wasn't as bad as it actually was but
part of that is by design in other words
there was no actual effort made by the
federal government by the Trump
administration to really give an honest
accounting of what was going on there
and they stuck with this number of 64
for a very long time even though we knew
hundreds and ultimately thousands of
people were dying and I hate to break it
to you but things are still not going
particularly well in Puerto Rico a
friend of mine recently volunteered
there in April teaches high school and
during his break which was I think in
early April during his spring break he
went for a week to port
Rico paid his own way and then got in
touch with with people who were
volunteering there he said it's still a
terrible disaster at least was as a five
six weeks ago they were bringing food
supplies helping to set up generators in
different parts of the island and it was
absolutely horrible and it has been at
this point I mean how long has it been
at this point I had a while it's been
nine months or something like that or
about that much but yeah less fall right
yeah last fall cuz six six nine months
something like that but look black women
have never been so highly employed in
the United States and that's what trump
has been tweeting about as well as you
know Roseanne and how our veterans would
be really happy with the economy despite
you know having died and being the
reason why we're remembering them on
Memorial Day know tweet at all about
what's going on in Puerto Rico these are
Americans and I think that that is
something if I were to have to choose
one phrase that sort of epitomizes
everything that has been wrong with
Puerto Rico coverage and particularly
federal government responds its hey guys
we're talking about Americans and that's
not to say we shouldn't care about non
Americans right like it can be very easy
to hear me saying hey these are
Americans we should have treated them
better as me saying if they weren't
actually Americans we shouldn't care but
the point of mentioning it is to remind
you that this is part of the country
that the government completely failed in
its response the moral imperative to
help foreigners or not is something we
can debate and that I would defend but
what we have to remember is this should
be part of our evaluation of Trump's job
because these are ultimately Americans
and this is part of the United States
really really horrible what's going on
right now and I want to hear from you
about it I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the
show is on twitter at david pakman show
and we have just a fantastic program
planned for you today today's episode of
the program is made possible in part by
Cody which is an innovative new
cryptocurrency and online payment
platform that wants to revolutionize how
we send and receive online payments cody
stands for currency of the internet
and the goal is to build an
infrastructure for online payments that
simple transparent trustworthy
instantaneous as well as scalable and
today's payment solutions have a number
of different trust and usability
problems whether it's between consumers
or between businesses or between
consumers and businesses and Cody wants
to solve a lot of those problems through
their currency and platform which unlike
a lot of the Kryptos and block chains
that are out there have actually been
created specifically and solely to be
used for payments cody has set out to do
this by using innovative base layer
protocol in the form of a directed
acyclic graph based ledger built from
transactions connected through time by
harnessing trust based algorithms if
you're watching this on youtube you can
find out more about cody and their
initial coin offering in the links below
this video this is not financial advice
and everybody should do their own
research